okay I think I'm gonna go ahead and get
started it's five to two so thanks
everyone for coming to my talk density
based clustering in Python my name is
Brian Kent I'm a data scientist at dado
we're based in Seattle hopefully you've
seen all of our big fuchsia banners
everywhere if not stop by our booth
after the talk the talk is not really a
data talk I'll mention wanna one of the
tools in dado but I really want to talk
more about the method today so I want to
talk about density based clustering but
before I get started on that a little
bit of a baseline about what is
clustering and I think this might be
pretty intro for a lot of people so I'll
move pretty quickly through it but I
think it's important to start here the
idea is that we have a bunch of data
instances data points here I'm using the
two moons data drawn with psyche at
random state 19 by the end of this talk
you'll be really sick of this data set I
don't want to spend too much time
explaining the data so I'm gonna keep
using this over and over and over again
so bear with me the point of clustering
is to group the data points so that we
have similar instances in the same group
and dissimilar instances in different
groups sounds pretty easy but we don't
have a target variable so we're not
going to split this into a training and
testing phases we need to do this
without any supervision and so this is
kind of what we want the answer to be
we've colored the points based on the
true groups they were drawn from here so
we want to get some output like this
blue and red split so we're gonna sign
each point to a cluster so that's
clustering so why did we do this and so
I started with clustering from an
academic context and an academia had
sort of presented as an axiomatic thing
that we would want to do it's sort of a
foundational to our fundamental task in
statistics but now that I'm at a company
that's trying to sell a product I found
that it's actually a lot harder to sell
clustering as something that commercial
users would want to do things like
recommender systems and a classification
regression kind of sell themselves term
prediction etc everyone kind of knows
what those applications are but it's
been a little harder to find sales
points for clustering so I made a list
of the reasons why people do clustering
and if there are others awesome let me
know after the talk I'd love to add to
my list
the first thing and to mention this in a
lightning talk yesterday is exploring
and visualizing complex data so
clustering is often one of the first
things that we do as humans when we
start working with a new data set to get
some sense of the structure of that data
another thing that people use clustering
for often is to reduce the scale of the
data in some way it can be done in
either dimension either reducing the
number of instances or reducing the
dimensionality a very common application
and this is one that does have a lot of
commercial use is detecting outliers
which to me is a flavor of anomalies
there's lots of other types of anomalies
small clusters for example or clusters
with small mass but high density all of
these could be considered anomalies
deduplication is a fascinating
clustering example because we often
think of clustering as trying to find a
small number of groups in that Moon's
example I have two groups but
deduplication if you have n records you
might want n minus two clusters there
might only be two duplicates or
something like that so it is a
clustering problem but it's a very
specific form of clustering it's very
different from the usual applications
and finally people often talk about
using clustering to segment market or a
user base I've put this last because I'm
not really sure what the purpose is of
that usually there's some other purpose
but it's a kind of thing where people do
clustering because I don't know what
else to do to get started so that that
is the reason to do it if you don't
meaning else to do try closely so
there's a few key takeaways from today
now that we've got the basics down the
first is that k-means is not always a
good option and this was the I think the
big point for the light and talk
yesterday so I agree with that
completely there are reasons to use
k-means we'll go into that but it's not
always a great option and the point of
this talk is that density based
clustering is a particular flavor or
family of methods that's sometimes a
good alternative DB scan is the most
popular form so I spend a lot of time
explaining how that works
level set trees is something that I've
worked on for a long time it's a more
powerful method than DB scan I believe
and finally I'll go through some code
pretty quickly with scikit-learn
with graph lab create and with my own
package debacle so k-means is kind of a
default clustering method and part of
the origin for this is before this talk
is that I was talking to someone in
DevOps and he was
talking about how he did a clustering
problem for some sort of system and I
asked him why he used k-means and he
said it's because the only thing he knew
and so that was sort of why I wanted to
talk about different kinds of clustering
because k-means is the default but there
are other things out there but why do
people do it why did it become the
default well it's a very simple
algorithm for one there are there are
lots of resources out there to learn
about how K means works there's lots of
implementations pretty much any generic
statistics or machine learning package
is going to have some form of k-means
clustering in it and it scales very well
so if you have truly massive data
k-means can be a good option especially
with the some more recent
implementations of this mini-batch in
particular can be extremely fast and
still yields pretty good results so as
an aside about k-means if you're doing
k-means and you're using the original
algorithm you're probably doing it wrong
I can't guarantee that
there I'm sure there's good uses for it
but you're probably doing it wrong so if
you want to know more about that come
see me afterward ok so here's an example
where k-means is not the only answer so
the first question we have to ask is how
do we choose K and k-means and of course
there is something called the elbow
heuristic or the gap heuristic where
we're gonna try K knees with a bunch of
different values of K and find out where
the error stops decreasing quickly and
choose that as our value of K and that
sounds great in principle but in
practice it doesn't work that well in my
experience sometimes choosing K is
impossible so deduplication is a great
example of this where if K you know
might be on the range from 2 to 20 it's
one thing to try this gap heuristic if K
is on the range from 1 to n and n is
10,000 it's pretty tough to do that gap
statistic so sometimes choosing K is
just impossible deduplication being a
great example and finally k-means only
find spherical convex clusters and so
when we have this two moons example this
is why I chose the two moons example
k-means fails so here we have clustered
with k-means into the red and blue
points and the answer is terrible ok so
the next part of the talk is the
overview about density based clustering
and this is sort of what we
want to do with density based clustering
so don't think about this yet as a
specific algorithm this is a concept
about what we would want to achieve with
density based clustering and the premise
here is that the data is drawn from an
unknown underlying probability density
function so this is a statistical view
of the world there is some unknown PDF
and we're drawing data from it the PDF
basically describes for any point in our
space how likely it is to draw a data
instance from that point so what we
would want to do is take this data and
estimate that PDF so I've drawn our
estimated PDF with color here with
contour lines so it's you know where the
regions where the data lies in those two
moons is where we have high estimated
PDF what we would want to do is in
threshold this PDF this estimated
density function and we find that upper
level set so here i've cut it at point
two and I've taken that region in our
space that has a higher estimated
density than point two and so from here
what we would like to do is then find
the connected components and so keep
this in mind I'm going to come back to
this in a minute what we want to do is
find two connected components of that
upper level set then we're going to
intersect our original data with that
upper level set so imagine our data in
those regions and then use that
intersection to label the data data
points themselves so this would be our
final clustering with our ideal density
based clustering routine so pros and
cons of this idea first off we can
recover much more complex cluster shapes
so this is the idea that we get these
moons which k-means couldn't do could
only recover spheres or hyper spheres we
don't need to know K so this is a big
benefit of course we have to know some
other parameters depending on which
specific method we choose but we don't
need to know the number of clusters a
priori we can automatically find
outliers so if you saw on that last last
image we had some black points that
weren't actually assigned to a cluster
that's a good candidate for an outlier
so those are the pros the cons we need
some sort of function to measure the
dissimilarity or the distance between
each pair of points or a given pair of
points and so some methods encode this
automatically other methods allow you to
specify
however you want but we need to have
some measure of this dissimilarity
incidentally k-means does this
implicitly and so that's one of the
problems with it is this can't change it
without changing the algorithm it's not
generally as scalable as k-means because
we have to compute a lot of those
distance functions and finally last but
not least it's impossible to do what I
just described because computing those
topologically connected components is
computationally impossible and so I
don't want to get into the details of
what I mean by topologically this is
just common sense connected components
we have this region in space we need to
decide if there's any path between these
two regions this is a computationally
impossible task so this is where we
start getting into lots of different
density based clustering methods
specific flavors of this and so because
there's no well there are several ways
to measure the quality of clustering but
it's not nearly as clear-cut as
something that's supervised these
methods have proliferated but DB scan is
far and away the most popular form of
density waves clustering so dense DB
scan stands for density based spatial
clustering of applications with noise so
people assume it has something to do
with databases and there is some
distance loose connection there but it
really is not about databases its
density base spatial clustering of
applications with noise it's from Martin
Esther and other authors in 1996 so it's
a relatively old algorithm now but it
won the test of time award just last
year at the kdd conference so people are
still using this and in fact it is amass
7400 citations so it's far beyond the
scikit-learn threshold of when to
implement to model or not which is like
200 or so 300 oh okay good but isolation
forest is okay so the main idea of DB
scan wow this is again a very high level
idea is that we're going to partition
our data into three types of points
we're not going to this isn't the
clustering yet but each point is going
to be assigned to either the core group
a boundary group or a noise group and so
the core points are the high density
points these are the points at the
center of clusters loosely speaking they
have lots of neighbors within a certain
distance around them and so the next
thing to do with to connect
these core points into the clusters and
then to assign the boundary points to a
nearby cluster and the noise points are
left is noise okay so now there's a
great visualization if my internet is
working okay so I'm gonna click out of
here
and see if we can get this going this is
not mine I don't know the author but
it's a fantastic violation of how this
works sort of on a local scale in a
breadth-first way as opposed to k-means
so we're gonna start with this very
noisy data set here I'm gonna click the
the parameters up a little bit so it's a
little faster and we're gonna go so we
start with an arbitrary point we expand
the neighborhood around that point to
include other core points and we just
keep doing this in a breadth-first way
until we run out of nearby core point
neighbors and so this blue cluster
continues expanding around the outside
of the smiley face even though we've
were far beyond a convex shape at this
point it will just keep expanding at a
local fashion the red point the red
cluster is already stopped there's no
more neighbors to be found around that
cluster that this is random noise so
this is not something I've seen before
it's always different which is cool but
I don't really know exactly how it's
gonna go so hopefully we get some new
clusters now with the mouth and the
other eye it's moving slowly slowly
slowly yeah so it's working well yeah so
it's I mean so then these black points
are the noise points which aren't gonna
be assigned to a cluster and so it's
it's fairly robust to that that order
order does matter but in a very very
small way it matters in how the boundary
points are assigned to a cluster because
they're assigned to the first core
cluster that they see but if it picks a
noise point and there aren't sufficient
number of neighbors around it just moves
on to the next point it marks it as
visited and then moves on to the next
point so it's pretty robust to that
so is that pretty clear I love that
illustration any questions about that
yeah I don't think it was reassigned I
think it was on the edge of rad I think
it was a weird case but I don't think it
was reassigned yeah it shouldn't I mean
not I don't this is not Feli Harris I
don't know who this is
there could be a bug but yeah yeah
unless there's above I don't think it
could have been if it's done right yeah
yeah
yeah I mean the question is about high
dimensional spaces I'm not sure about
the specific the answer that specific
question but in general high dimensional
spaces are going to be problems for
these distance based methods because all
the distances are going to look similar
as the dimension gets really high there
is a middle ground I mean that's part of
the reason why we did this in graph lab
create is because we're trying to expand
the usefulness of this method to work
with some medium dimension data like
images for example but once you get into
really high dimensions it's not going to
work that well none of these methods
will work that well it's true yep
oh okay so now I wanted to show how to
do TV scan in scikit-learn so then go
back to a Jupiter notebook here I'm
actually gonna move this up a little bit
how's the font size good people okay
great yeah yeah he says it's okay so
it's okay okay so we're gonna import our
libraries matplotlib so I can show
what's happening the make moons function
from Circular and so I can generate this
data and the DB scan function from
scikit-learn and of course I'll use the
G be GG plot style and matplotlib
because it's awesome not at the moment
but I'll post it it's good idea
okay so here's just the top top five
rows of our data so just to see what it
looks like we've got an N by 2 matrix
here it's very straightforward at the
end scikit-learn so this is I mean this
is really simple code this is not meant
to be a tutorial about how to make super
high awesome a super high level awesome
machine learning you know whiz-bang
things this is pretty simple code model
equals DB skin so that the trick here is
the parameters and so there's two main
parameters for DB skin the first is
epsilon F PPS here and this defines the
size of the neighborhood around each
point the second is min samples which is
the number of points that have to be
within that epsilon neighborhood for a
point to be considered a core point so
men samples is basically our density
level threshold so when I picked point
two on that contour plot this is
analogous to the min samples value so
we'll make that model and we'll print it
so scikit-learn doesn't print too much
when you print the model but we can see
the parameters that we use to make the
model and of course with fit we've
already fit the data to it on the
chained operation here so what comes out
of this pretty straightforward model
labels so these are our cluster labels
the renders a little strange here but
basically we have ones and zeros because
we have two clusters with this moons
example there's one negative one in here
that stands for the noise point and then
of course there's the core sample
indices as well which is useful too
which points are the core points so we
can check that this worked pretty well
with the matplotlib plot and we get some
strange warning but basically our red
point is the noise point here and the
gray and the orange are our clusters so
works pretty well so based on those
parameters the epsilon and mid neighbors
parameter it's not so the reason it's
noise is that it itself is not a core
point it doesn't have sufficient number
of neighbors but it also none of its
neighbors are core points as well so it
can't be a boundary point it can't be
assigned to one of the core points so it
means at this point is also a boundary
point and this points probably a
boundary point that's Sarah yeah yeah
that's a great question so the second
part of the talk is about level set
trees which are in part intended to get
around that problem yeah yeah
yeah so it doesn't it does support more
more distances which is one of the great
features about these distance based
methods you have to compute some
distances but you can choose your
distance so there's a pretty pretty wide
range of distances and I'll come back to
that a little bit for the GraphLab
create version as well the complexity is
the funky issue it's kind of a funny
story because the original paper says
that it's n log n if you already have a
nearest neighbors indexing structure
where you can quickly look up the region
around each point which is wonderful if
you have that great but I don't usually
have that what's funny is there's a
paper that came out this year or last
year that actually finds a mistake in
the original paper and corrects the
rates to be worst case N squared but in
practice when log n is not a terrible
guess if you have an index indexing
structure that is the bigger bigger part
yeah other questions okay great let's
see okay so I'm gonna go back to the
slides real quick and talk a little bit
about DB scan and graphlab create so I
guess the question is why did we do this
if it's already inside cute learn the
first thing is we wanted to build this
on top of the graph lab create s frame
with s graph data structures so if
you've heard word rats talk earlier or
you come by the booth you know that
these are our scalable data structures
they're on disk parallel computation etc
both open source both awesome but we
wanted to build a tool that worked with
these natively the second thing is this
distance question so we have this idea
of a composite distance because a lot of
our customers and users want to work
with features that have different types
so they want to work with say string
data for say a house address and
Euclidian data for lot size and square
footage or something like that so we
have numeric data and they have string
data they want to have some function
that measures the the dissimilarity
between two points based on these
different features so Euclidean distance
for example only works with the America
data it's not going to work so we have a
composite distance where you can add
different distance functions on
different sets of features and this can
be sent to DB scan as well that said
there's a big caveat with this which is
that the the DB scan algorithm doesn't
explicitly talk about how which
properties if distance functions are
needed to work well but if you give it a
weird really weird distance function you
might get really weird answers back
that's the test the caveat
and the third thing is so the original
algorithm if you've noticed a lot I
didn't talk about in great detail but
basically is doing a connected component
search on a graph and so we thought by
doing that connected component search
directly we could use it more efficient
algorithm and speed up the speed up the
process a little bit and in fact when we
wrote it it was pretty it was faster
than scikit-learn
so I could learn has made some great
improvements so it's pretty much on par
at this point so I would say that's a
wash lastly of course DB scan graph like
rate is not open source but free for
non-commercial use send free to try so
check it out okay and I want it now I
wanted to show off what that looks like
in graph type create as well ok so again
I don't want to wear too much about the
the S frame code here I'm importing
graph lab I'm converting it to RS frame
the numpy array into an S frame I'm
going to create a model I get a little
bit of output here and we're going to
look at the summary of that model this
is the key thing that I like to look at
here so this gives us some sense of what
went into our models the way you have a
number of examples this is the schema of
the model so to speak a number of
columns we have two columns in our
original data set we have our parameters
our radius parameter we call it radius
instead of Epsilon and the min mid
number of neighbors to be a core point
our density level threshold training
time etc so how do we use this well we
get a table that describes the cluster
ID for each point and we also get a
column in this that indicates the type
of the point so this can be useful as
well if you want to say plot your data
by instance type so if you want to look
at say the boundary points which are
points where you might have less
certainty about which cluster it belongs
to or Noi's points for example so I'm
going to do that the machinery here
isn't too important let's let's ignore
that for now I just wanted to show how
you would use this result to make a plot
with the boundary points here so in this
plot the gray now is the boundary points
according to the DB scan algorithm the
red points are the core points and again
we have this orange Point which is our
noise sorry for the changing colors then
still getting used to the matplotlib
color maps
any questions at this point great okay
so there's one another example I wanted
to show here which is starting to get
into that idea of different distances
and here it's sort of deduplication I'm
losing the term deduplication loosely
basically what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take a small sample of
Wikipedia articles here
pardon the rendering again and that the
title is for some reason lost their
spaces but this is title and then text
so aquaculture and then output is
reported from aquaculture world etc ad
hominem etc so this is some random
sample of Wikipedia articles the text of
Wikipedia articles and there's a little
bit of feature engineering I'm going to
convert this into a bag of words
representation details aren't super
critical if you're interested please
talk to me afterwards so now instead of
just a long string of text for each
article we have dictionary which
represents the number of times that each
word appears in our in each article that
is going to go well the first one never
moves to stop words and then we're going
to create the DB scan model and I'm not
going to do it here it takes about a
minute I want to keep moving but I'm
going to load a pre train model but the
idea is here I'm using Jaccard distance
I'm not using Euclidean distance so I've
changed up yeah that's grass web create
yep yep and so here my radius is 0.6 so
what's your car distance I actually have
some intuition about what that means
basically the ratio of the intersection
of the words and the union of the words
between two articles have to be a
certain level so I'm going to load this
model start even trained and show you
the summary we have 14 and a half
thousand articles roughly we have one
hundred and twelve clusters so this is
an exactly BBC duplication rather but
it's closer to that than the other
applications so one thing I wanted to
touch on real quickly this is the canvas
feature and GraphLab create so I wanted
to show basically the distribution on
the cluster ID so first of all there's
14,000 of our 14 and a half thousand
that are undefined these are the noise
points so this clustering routine found
a lot of noise which is OK in a
deduplication case the noise doesn't
mean it's bad it just means we didn't
find anything to cluster it with we can
look at the distribution of clusters
here and see that it's pretty
skewed so there's one set of clusters
one set of articles that are really
similar to each other and the rest are
kind of all in their own little world
I'm gonna go back and I wanted to
explore the clusters now just to show
you what these clusters look like so
I'll join the original data back to my
cluster IDs and then I'll print some of
these out and you can see that this
particular cluster number ten is
National Historic Places
so Glencoe Maryland it was listed in the
National Register of Historic Places
Douglass place was listed on the
National Historic historical register
national historical places so we have
some reason to believe that this is
working even with non-traditional
distance on some fairly complex data
questions at this point okay cool I did
I did absolutely yeah so that's a good
question so it scales so the big
challenge there's two pieces to this
there's finding the nearest neighbors
for each point so the all point nearest
neighbors and then there's finding the
connected components in the graph those
are the two big pieces and so the
nearest neighbors part is sort of its
own well studied problem it can scale
depending on the attributes of the data
it's not all pairs necessarily so it's
not necessarily an N squared problem but
it's it is computationally expensive the
connected components is meanness it's
not nearly as bad but it also takes some
time yeah okay right now at brute-force
yeah so we don't have the dual tree
enabled yet partly because we want it to
be as general as possible so we should
be one of the next steps just to make
this a bit more automated in terms of
which indexing structures used for the
nearest neighbors part right now it's
brute force because it's the most
flexible yeah yep
yep okay so I'm gonna switch gears a
little bit now and talk about why DB
scan is not perfect itself and why level
set trees are better than DB skin this
is a bit of an aggressive claim I'm not
really that aggressive about it but in
trying to get the message across so I'm
sure a DB scan aficionados in the room
we can have a great argument about this
that's not really the point so again how
do we choose those parameters in DB scan
the density level in particular Epsilon
okay I can say how you might have some
sense for what a radius might be like
with Jaccard distance you might have
some common sense intuition about what
that might be but how do you choose a
density level I don't know if you need
to change the density level the mid name
Burres parameter you have to start from
scratch with DB skin so level set trees
is something I've worked a bit on in
grad school they describe the entire
hierarchy of the density based clusters
they allow you to retrieve clusters in
different ways and repeatedly without
starting from scratch
the tree was the tree is computed it's
exists and you could just query it as
many times as you want and whatever way
you want you don't need to recompute it
each cluster could have a different
density level so one of the issues with
DB scan is you have to pick a flat level
with these trees you can pick clusters
at different levels so if you have
clusters that have different densities
you can retrieve all of them and this is
a very useful visualization of high
dimensional or complex data so DB scan
you can plot the points back in feature
space but you don't really have a great
sense for what the structure is of the
data the hierarchy gives you a better
sense for that topological structure of
the data okay so how do you build a
level set tree this is first some text
bullets about the process and then I'll
show a little bit of illustration on the
two moons data so first we're gonna
estimate the PDF at each point this was
like we started off with our original
density based clustering concept what
estimate the PDF at each point we're
going to construct a similarity graph on
the data similar to our DB scan
implicitly is doing
we're so similarity graph if you're not
familiar each vertex is going to stand
for one of the data points and we'll put
an edge between a pair of data points if
they are neighbors of each other we're
going to then filter through this graph
and the way we do this is we're going to
remove vertices in order of estimated
density so we'll take the minimum
estimate a density point and we'll take
it away from the graph and all the edges
that are attached to it and as we do
that we'll compute the connected
components so a very similar is so far
to DB scan but we're gonna keep track of
these components between levels and as
it happens they make a tree so here's
kind of what it looks like with our
standard two moons data so we have the
same data set I've colored it by
estimated density so the the warmer
colors the darker Reds are higher
estimated density the lighter whites are
lower estimate density so that's the
first step
now I've constructed a similarity graph
and I represented this with black lines
between pairs of points and so the thing
to know here is that we have one
component we have one cluster at this
level at level zero basically yes so I
used the K nearest neighbor similarity
graph so if so for a pair of points if
either one is one of the others K
nearest neighbors I drew a line between
them yep okay so because there's one
component we have one cluster
represented in our tree there's no tree
yet this is the root of the tree okay so
now this is the low density point
circled in blue so basically what
happens here to step back three things
can happen three one of several things
can happen when a point is removed
either nothing can happen which is what
happens in this case so we take it out
the one component stays the same nothing
changes so we represent that with
another point on our tree it's the same
same place horizontally but just a
little higher because at that point had
a particular density and it was point O
seven it's very hard to see but it was
point O seven so now we've put our put
our dot there
so we keep doing that and nothing is
happening until suddenly remove at one
more point and now a different thing has
happened
our first cluster has died and we've
split into two clusters so a river the
way we represent on the tree is first
I'm not going to use these points I'm
just going to present that one cluster
by a horizontal line and then I'm going
to have a split represented by a
vertical line the split is represented
by a horizontal line so now we have two
clusters growing from those branches
right now we do this again we remove
points one by one by one nothing has
happened in either one of those clusters
until we have two points left our tree
kind of looks like this we move that one
point this is the third thing that can
happen a cluster disappears it didn't
split it just vanishes so those are the
things that can happen as we filter
through this graph we end up with this
tree structure kind of looks like a
field goal for the two moons case
doesn't always look like that so that's
that's kind of the basic idea what it
looks like in code let's switch to
debacle here again we're gonna make the
same data set
so I've imported debacle as DCL here
just for syntactic brevity I'm gonna use
the construction tree command so it
takes data it takes this parameter k
which is a connectivity parameter
analogous to epsilon and DB scan this is
the parameter that I use to build that K
nearest neighbor graph this is K pruning
threshold is not really related to the
density level or the connectivity but
basically what happens if we don't prune
we get a lot of little tiny leaves with
one or two points in them so I'm just
gonna say if a leaf has fewer than 10
points just merge it with its siblings
just makes the tree a little smoother so
make this tree and then we'll print it
well that's that's terrible let me
shrink it a little bit
basically the tree this the point is not
to digest all of the numbers in this
tree the point is that this is all of
the information in the tree it's a very
compact data structure three lines and a
table that's all it is well the size
here hides the fact that we keep the
indices of the points that belong to
each of those nodes as well but then we
plot it and we get our our field goal
again so to retrieve clusters we could
do this in one of them anyway so this is
the get clusters method get clusters
function and it takes a method parameter
and first we're going to do this with
leaf so leaf leaf clusters are just the
ones that are the leaves of the tree
these are the high density modes of the
tree so look at those I printed the
first five just to show you what it
looks like the first column the left
column is the row index the second
column is the cluster label and integer
label and then I'll plot those to show
you what it looks like again so we have
the same output life is good notice that
we don't have all of the points plotted
so the points that were pruned off
before we split are not part of this
clustering right now those are the noise
points and of course we can then go back
and replac this tree so that our colors
match so here we have red and gray those
red and gray points came from the red
and gray leaves of this tree so the next
thing we want to do is identify outliers
so let's go back and find points that
are low-density and instead of fiying
the high-density clusters and so what we
can do we can do this is again
the tree get clusters method will do the
upper-level set one thing you might want
to do is look at the points that are in
the bottom 5% so what are the low 5
percent density points so that's what
I'll do here I'll cut at a single
density level much like DB scan does and
I'll get the the 0.05 percent points so
these are those points these are the low
density points and then we can plot
those same plot as before but now I've
added those in black so now we found our
low density points so I'm sure they're a
lot of questions let me hold off because
I just have one more slide or a couple
more slides one more concept here that's
the basics but you might say okay well
DB scan was already pretty good at
finding two clusters pretty much any
parameter in there we would have found
two clusters so why do we really need
level set trees well here's an example
of much more complex data so these are
hurricane tracks in the Atlantic from
1950 ish to 2014 ish I've plotted them
according to some estimate of density
let's not get into specifics about
density on functions but even with some
coloring about the density it's still
really hard to figure out what's going
on in this data set we cannot visualize
this and see the structure there's just
too much over plotting going on so we'll
make the tree and the top upper left we
get those leaf clusters we plot those
clusters back in our original feature
space and we have a much better set to
the organization of these tracks so
that's pretty much it
debacle is my own thing HIPAA stall
debacle help is definitely wanted if
you're interested and playing with this
stuff the wrap-up just to reiterate
k-means is not always the best option
sometimes it is but think twice before
you do it that's all I'm asking density
based clustering can be a good
alternative DB scan is the place to
start if you're just started getting
started with with density based
clustering check out code and
scikit-learn graph lab create and check
out level set trees and debacle if
you're interested thank you very much
okay a few minutes for questions I'm not
sure I quite understand the question
yeah yeah so in fact I have to yeah yeah
so the in fact I have to admit that
right now the implementation is pretty
dumb and does fine connected components
at every level but in fact I union-find
data structure or destroy data structure
would be a much better way to do this so
there is a prototype code on github for
this I just haven't sped it up yet I
haven't optimized it so that it's
actually faster than the connective
components version but it is
computationally a more efficient way to
do it yeah yeah good question I it's a
very it's a long answer and I completely
smooth over it so I just used the points
in space so the geo chords for each
point so each of these hurricane tracks
has somewhere between 10 and 100 or so
points so it's a variable number of
points which makes it a little bit
trickier and I use the distance called
max average min sometimes called chamfer
distance to measure the distance between
any pair of tracks yeah Andres yeah it's
so there's a paper by audrey and desk
gupta from UC san diego I think 2010 ish
that has an algorithm but it's a very
theoretical algorithm it has
continuously varying variables from 0 to
infinity and it's very computationally
inefficient so I modified it a bit to be
a bit more reasonable for practical use
yeah mm-hmm I know the questions great
thank you
you